fastest anyone's ever done to 5 million
correct facebook took about 10 months to
get to a million yeah uh twitter took a
couple years now in fairness a little
bit of a different time smartphones are
a bit different but it just shows you
the scale and how quickly it's moving
and i think it's because we're at the
convergence of what's hot politically
but also what's hot with the economy
jason didn't you get like a million on
day one or week one something like that
what what how how did you guys do on uh
uh how long did it take to get to a
million three days three days two
million three days was that because of
uh joe rogan or that that had nothing to
do with a joke that was so joe came
along six months later although so we're
million in three days a million and a
half in about 10 days uh we're three
million people at the end of this last
year end of 2021 uh after joe rogan and
tucker carlson dr robert malone some
other folks we grew by 50
by a million and a half users just in
the month of january of this year so
we're off to a great start and it's the
surge is real so go ahead do you think
that's a function of you know economic
supply and demand there's a major demand
for a free speech platform is there
something specific about getter that
people said i got to get on that
specific platform or was it just sort of
a sign of the times where it's like look
clearly the big tech overlords are sort
of limiting and shadow banning and hey
here's a cool new platform i can check
out what's the unique uh position both
and the reason why i say that is i
always kind of use the analogy to
channel my inner george bailey the every
time twitter facebook or youtube kicks
someone off of their platform another
getter angel gets its wings and so it
might be terrible for democracy but when
they kick people off they look and say
you know what what else is there they
see getter and they want to come on
board but part of the reason is and you
know patrick you hit on this in a really
great segment about a year ago where he
said i'm tired of republicans whining
and saying uh you know big tech you're
bad but then not doing anything about it
i've heard that and i said you know what
i am going to do it i'm going to put
some money behind it gonna go build a
real platform here's the one dynamic i
would have added to your um very
eloquent
going off of a year ago
people have come up with alternative
platforms before but the user interface
hasn't been that good the
functionalities look clunky kind of
junior varsity or b team nobody looks
and says hey twitter your functionality
is poor your user experience is poor i
want to go to some other platform they
say i'm tired of the political
discrimination i want to move
when you launch a new platform you have
to be as good if not better as the big
tech platforms if you want users to stay
even if people are turned off
ideologically by what twitter's doing it
has to be a top-notch product and that's
what we've set out to do with getter so
first of all i applaud you for doing
that because i think
uh uh
you know the fact that somebody is
saying let me go out there and do this
everybody's talking let me do something
about it and uh create another
alternative for them so and i think in
today's
climate
the current ceo of twitter probably
helps you more than dorsey does because
he seems to be more about
what what account guy canceled yesterday
330 6 000 followers or two days ago just
because they took a screenshot of other
people's tweets and they they shut them
down yeah so for anyone who is watching
the listening there's an account called
defiant ls define and then a capital l
apostrophe s this is a great account
where all they do is say here's a tweet
from yeah defiant else oh they're back
uh they're back now okay they're
phenomenal and they're also on twitter
just for anyone watching define l's is
on getter uh which is great so they were
never canceled there that's crazy
because they were at 3 35 two days ago
they're at 5 10 now so this cancellation
got more eyeballs so that went to your
point also from your segment from a year
ago where you said do you just elevate
people off of some of these
cancellations which the answer is yes i
mean take a look at
look at nicki minaj for example or kyrie
irving not two people who'd say have
traditional
bases of support saying the right of
center type space but now that there
were efforts to try to cancel them uh
because of their positions on uh covet
vax treatments things like that now they
become almost pop culture heroes and
sometimes they don't even have to be
someone who's uh take a look at enos
canter freedom who was with the boston
celtics and then was just released by
the rockets and what pretty clearly is a
retaliatory pushback because he's been
going off on the nba in china and then
we'll get into china a little bit more
later he's now a hero to people all over
the world because he's standing up to
the ccp so some of these efforts to
cancel people but i want to go stick on
the define ls for one moment just to
tell you how the idiocy of what's going
on here all this account does i
shouldn't say all because that discounts
it but what they do is they take an old
tweet in a current tweet and it's just
basically the person taking a loss
here's where they've contradicted
themselves and some of these things that
they find are so damning like you don't
know whether to laugh or to cry there's
something these are saying it's
contradictory yes
but all it does is post what someone
said before and what they're saying now
just to absolutely thunder these people
and they got taken down literally for
just posting um just taking screenshots
from twitter so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]